- [Teacher] We're given
an f of x and they say,
what is the coefficient for the term
containing x plus two to the fourth power
in the Taylor polynomial,
centered at x equals negative two of f?
So like always, see if you
can take a stab at this video
on your own before we
work through it together.
Alright, now let's do this.
So in general, our Taylor
polynomial, p of x,
it's going to have the form and remember,
we're centering at x equals negative two
so this means we're going
to evaluate our function
at where we're centering it.
We are going to divide
it by zero factorial
which is just one.
I'm just gonna write 'em all
out just so you see the pattern
and we could even say
that's gonna be times
x minus where we're centering it
but if we're subtracting a negative two,
it's gonna be x plus two and I
could write to the zero power
but once again, that's
just going to be one
so a lot of times, you won't
see someone write this and this
but I'm writing it just to show
that there's a consistent pattern.
So then you're gonna have
plus the first derivative
evaluated at negative two
divided by one factorial
which is still just one
times x plus two to the first power
plus the second derivative
evaluated at negative two
over two factorial times
x plus two squared.
I think you see where this is going
and really all we care about is the one
that has a fourth degree term and,
well, actually, let me just
write the third degree term too
just so we get fluent doing this.
So the third derivative
evaluated at negative two
over three factorial times x
plus two to the third power
and now, this is the part
that we really care about,
plus the fourth derivative.
I could have just written a four there
but I think you get what I'm saying.
And then evaluate at x equals negative two
divided by four factorial times x plus two
to the fourth power.
So what's the coefficient here?
Well, the coefficient is this business.
So we'd have to take the fourth derivative
of our original function.
We gotta take the fourth derivative
of that original function,
evaluate at negative two
and divide it by four
factorial so let's do that.
So our function,
so our first derivative, f
prime of x is just going to be,
just gonna use the power rule a lot,
six x to the fifth minus three x squared.
Second derivative is going to be equal to
five times six is 30 x to the fourth.
Two times three, minus
six x to the first power.
Third derivative.
Third derivative of x
is going to be equal to
four times 30 is 120 x to the third power
minus six and then the fourth derivative
which is what we really care about
is going to be three times 120
is 360 x to the second power
and the derivative of a
constant is just zero.
So if we were to evaluate
this at x equals negative two,
so f, the fourth derivative,
evaluated when x equals negative two
is going to be 360 times
negative two squared is four.
I'm just gonna keep
that as 360 times four.
We can obviously evaluate that
but we're gonna have to
divide it by four factorial
so the whole coefficient is
going to be 360 times four
which is the numerator here
divided by four factorial,
divided by four times
three times two times one.
Well, four divided by four,
those are just gonna be one.
360 divided by three, maybe
I'll think of it this way,
360 divided by six is going to be 60
and so that's all we have.
We have 60 and then in the
denominator we just have a one
so this is going to simplify to 60.
That's the coefficient for this term.